all right let's continue next with uh
how about Josh from Florida Josh from
Florida Welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
hello can you hear me yes
perfect
um
yeah with uh DeSantis going you know
full
crazy I would say uh what what can we do
you know in upcoming elections to sort
of curb his you know power grab
are you saying power grab within Florida
or the idea of a power grab by running
and winning the Republican primary
um kind of both but
I I'm thinking less and less he's
actually going to run for president and
if he does I'm thinking less and less
that he has a shot to win I mean I I
tend to agree with you on that I mean
here's the thing in Florida Florida has
become
an idea in a sense I don't know how else
to say it and it's of quite a right wing
idea the the thing even though Florida
has millions and millions of Democrats
and left leaning people and there are
beautiful left-leaning parts of Florida
Florida has become sort of the idea of
we're going to do whatever the hell we
want
and we're going to be anti-woke and
we're going to be for Freedom the way
they describe it freedom to spread covet
at UFC events I guess in the middle of a
pandemic whatever so the problem in
Florida to me is less about the
political makeup although it's quite
plausible that there are more
Republicans than Democrats but it's
about the strength that the right-wing
ideology has gained in Florida where a
lot of left-leaning people are just
disaffected and they're either thinking
about leaving or they just feel like
they politically don't have a home or
don't get involved in politics or
whatever the case may be so as a place
where many people move to Florida
obviously one approach would be have
more Democrats move to Florida and then
change the balance but it's not really
clear that that's a strategy I think it
really has to be about Democrats
rebuilding in Florida from the ground up
in a more modern way uh it's less about
like Debbie Wasserman Schultz's and and
more about some new type of Dem Democrat
I think there's going to have to be sort
of like a re-branding of Florida
Democrats in order to seize power back
from the way DeSantis has grabbed it
yeah the problem I feel is that
so many people look at
people who aren't you know progressives
Or democrats they look at a lot of stuff
and they go oh that's too radical for me
and and I'm like
what's so radical what's so radical
about
moving forward and progressing as a
society
yeah I mean here's the thing this goes
to what the caller earlier said
part of conservatism is conserving some
prior state of things now if you ask
them where is the pin that you would
drop in the timeline for what you want
to conserve some might say the 80s some
might say the 50s some might say right
before women could vote some could say
there were there were still slaves but
fundamentally it's the idea that we
should do things the way we used to do
them simply because it's the way we used
to do them and for a progressive that's
a fundamentally flawed idea
right I mean listen in think about all
of the areas in which we say it'd be
crazy to do things the way we used to do
them in medicine we're going to do
things the way we used to do them
because that's how we used to do them in
terms of Transportation we're going to
get rid of planes and get rid of cars
and go to horses in turn you know in all
of these different things uh we would
say that's crazy so why is it supposedly
acceptable in certain other areas I
think it's a flawed idea at its core
right
well I'm with you all right uh thank you
for everything you do Josh from Florida
thank you so very much for the call I
really do appreciate that